bom dia a todos
a 17 minutos para vos é voar é percebido
eo próprio consciência mãe é perceber de
fato de ser feliz é de fato uma escolha
ou não
são 17 minutos para ficar naquilo que é
essencial são 17 minutos que vão ajudar
a perceber os meus 40 anos e nós quando
já tem 40 anos
espero fazer muito mais e é uma versão
três datas a espumar com 40 anos e vamos
avançar em mais 91 e 91 tinha 15 anos
estava no décimo ano estava preparado
para mais um dia de escola normal
preparava eu estava sozinha em casa que
ele a empregada tenha faltado elas têm
um ladrão muitos anos mesmo que um dia
ela faltou foi o único dia durante
muitos anos em que ela esteve lá em casa
que faltou destacando que ele estava
sozinho em casa nesse posto estava
procuravam para mais um dia normal como
vos disse fui tomar banho em entrar na
casa de banho cheia porta cheia janela
ligar o aquecedor mãos permanente e foi
tomar um banho calma sem pressa e não
tenha pressa tinha só a loja da parte da
tarde
esta é a altura do bairro comecei a
sentir-me josa e minha primeira reação
foi sentar um no poder não era uma
banheira não levar
sentei-me de manhã porque não lembro de
mais nada
tentador faltou dizer se sustentado
estava na casa de banho vivia em
alvalade em lisboa
são prédios antigos e ainda tenha o
espectador na casa do im é um grande
jogo em 5/5 cansada desligou água e
cento à espera que a sensação 1 passasse
só encontrada duas horas e meia depois
espanha mas chega a casa e ovo o
aquecedor permanentes ou o som era
suposto a casa estava vazia e dita casa
do encontro já desmaiada chamaram o inem
e eu vou pro hospital santa maria
cinco horas depois acorda de coma e digo
eu acordei muito mal disposta a
concordar com muitas dores de cabeça e e
a primeira coisa que eu digo aos médicos
é e eu não sinto as pernas
os médicos na altura acharam que
eventualmente seria uma reação pós como
é normal
não não tiveram não se preocuparam muito
deixar o tempo passar mas com o tempo
vai a confirmação de fato eu não sentia
as pernas fizemos exames eo diagnóstico
foi usar um lar vida ou uma intoxicação
por monóxido de carbono gás que
entretanto se tenha formado na casa de
banho bom nos meses a seguir foram
passados em algo então foi palco então
eu não aguentam de facto não trago uma
grande experiência infelizmente estamos
a falar do álcool então conseguiu há 25
anos atrás e há 25 anos atrás ou então
na minha opinião estava preparado para
receber pessoas que não tinham esperança
eu tinha 15 anos que era a última coisa
que poderia tirar na altura era expressa
até porque não havia segundo os médicos
na altura nenhuma pessoa no mundo que
tivesse ficado paraplégica por causa de
uma intoxicação 19 promoveu cinco anos
portanto era muito difícil conseguir
convencer a marta ea família da marta
que eu não voltaria a andar tanto o
objetivo então era recuperar a
mobilidade e voltar à minha vida normal
afinal aconteceu é essa altura o sexto
quatro meses em alcoitão quando sai
voando com o meu pai e vou visitar volvo
ser consultada por 2009 neurologistas
conceituados especialistas nesta área
e tanto um como o outro não disseram o
tratamento para pessoas com sua condição
e produções mil dólares está a ser
testado no laboratório tanto pode sair
cá para fora daqui um ano
daqui a 10 20 30 ou nunca sei de uma
coisa que eu não disseram na altura foi
que eu tive até hoje foi que o time se
manter são duas coisas praça e acima de
tudo ser positiva como já era agora com
poucos meses de acidentes foi isso que
eu fiz eu continue a ser positiva
vim para lisboa e continuarei a fazer a
minha vida normal
voltei à escola
o time acabou o secundário eu vou para a
faculdade é na faculdade é a lima altura
é que os meus pais me perguntam se eu
conquistar um ano parada é fazer pressão
ou só que se eu quero dividir entre a
recuperação ea vida normal 2000 de 15
anos e acho que esta foi a primeira
grande decisão é uma grande primeira
escolha que eu fiz foi não eu quero
continuar a estudar
eu quero continuar a estar com os meus
amigos e nos intervalos assim fazer a
fisioterapia foi isso que eu fiz durante
os primeiros três anos tratamentos fiz
muita fisioterapia fiz muitos
tratamentos experimentais de tudo e de
facto de passar três anos
é eu consigo perceber que não havia
alterações físicas eu continuava a não
sentir da cintura pra baixo e aí uma uma
decisão quase minha de parar os
tratamentos indicaram apenas aquilo que
o fato estava fazia que era seguir à
noite namorar estar com os meus amigos
está na faculdade e continuar já estava
na escola na altura e na faculdade mais
tarde quando entrou na faculdade cadeira
de rodas foi perfeitamente normal andava
na nova também mas não vai rolar sim
existe há semanas em lisboa na faculdade
tive um período normal de amigos tudo
tudo normal no último ano da faculdade
eu sou convidada para estagiar numa
empresa de tecnologia que na altura se
estrear em bolsa e portanto é precisava
de alguém para fazer a ponte com os
jornalistas porque meu curso era
precisamente era jornalismo
fiquei é ficar nessa empresa no dia da
corrida da entrevista curiosamente não
quiser não procurar mais ninguém deram
essa oportunidade
estou há 17 antes nessa empresa ainda
hoje estão na empresa é nova base onde
vocês que a conhecem quando sua
assessora de imprensa na bola já não é
uma empresa que nina é uma empresa
enorme com 2.500 colaboradores
espalhados pelo mundo e hoje nova base
maior empresa do mundo de tecnologias
sediada em portugal isto
em 91 de 91 é até à data que vão passar
agora que é a segunda data marca os meus
40 anos 2005 em 2005 para explicar para
você ficar aqui o carinho esta esta data
temos que recuar a 2004 - no final de
em 2004 eu tive um problema de vesícula
normal em que fui precisa precisa de ser
operada perder muito peso
tive um facto muito entre deixem me
imenso eu costumo dizer que uma meta
enquanto tiver morrer
e foi o que aconteceu eu não continuar
durante muito tempo é esperar que elas
precisam passar até que foi à praia da
vila mas quanto ao prazo que o sul foi a
solução eu já estava muito magrinha é já
tinha perdido muito peso e já tinha
feito uma chácara na ficha do rabo
estarão em tempo sentada nas escadas por
ter lançado sofridas muito fundas
sofridas que as pessoas cadeira de rodas
ou camadas o como habilidade mais dúvida
fazem com alguma frequência eo próprio é
um mito a yes caras
durante toda a minha para a cozinha é só
que esta é de controlá-los
estas cara é infectou com a infecção eu
continuo a achar que era nada comigo
continuar e ser indicado à espera que
isto mas as duas vezes melhorar outras
vezes pirava mas é importante aprender
cada vez mais peso e ficando cada vez
mais bonita e de facto foi foi um
período muito complicado até porque a
minha mãe silva no hospital
os padres não passa está sendo desviado
magritte uma espécie de convulsão em
casa e minha mãe é leva para o hospital
já não sei eu estava com uma septicemia
em último grau
os médicos disseram marta está com uma
infecção generalizada para quem não sabe
o cm é uma infecção generalizada no
corpo em que é qualquer momento um órgão
vital pode parar e quando isso acontece
nós praticamos identificarem o primeiro
treinamento com as contas qual é muito
sério mas isso não acaba mal
eu tô aqui a saúde tanto
levantada é o primeiro treinamento e
dois meses é para tudo na minha vida
parou tudo eu nunca tinha entrado no
hospital nunca tinha nenhuma doença
e naquela altura quando entrarem entrar
e fica em dois meses durante esses dois
meses os médicos basicamente fizeram foi
tentar de alguma forma controlar a
infecção causada por uma bactéria que já
que não identificar e que estavam a
tentar controlar a infecção vai passar
dois meses conseguiram é eu passei a
fazer cada vez menos quebra e com cinco
vencê los normalmente consigo convencer
as pessoas a fazer quer conseguir
convencê los a deixarem ir para casa
porque era tudo menos o meio ambiente
deixou para casa com uma condição de
voltar a fazer sexo eu tinha que voltar
para o hospital
o que aconteceu eu voltar a fazer phelps
é e nessa altura eu já tinha muitos
meses de perder peso de andar sempre a
cunhada sempre uma resposta já tinha
dois meses e tal de treinamento e já
estava muito desgastada e nessa altura
eu lembro quando voltar essa de phelps
isso acontece eu vou eu vou levar minha
casa sempre com esta condição de deixar
o fizesse para voltar eu vou vender
casas e três e quatro vezes e às tantas
já estava há muitos meses em ambiente do
hospital com alguns intervalos como
explicar e prefira casa
da última vez quando sinto em casa os
sintomas de febre vou pôr outro momento
de fato tinha e ligar minha mãe não tem
febre e ele respondeu bom então espero
já sabemos o que temos de fazer na
altura quebrar pela primeira vez em
muitos anos porque já na altura da
cadeira de rodas e nunca tinha tido uma
quebra nessa altura quebrar e ele se
farta disto alcançada tom completamente
no meu limite e diz em urbanizar e
animais por morrer já agora porque eu já
não aguento mais
seja rápido vai orientar melhor os
alimentos a minha mais profunda e só
quem não conhece a letra a chave para
provar
em lágrimas é nesta altura a minha mãe
de ismail é marta rápida vai investir 15
minutos a e hospital onde resolver isto
já vai ser esta recifes e assim foi
voltei pro hospital já que se situa na
agenda desta reportagem
até a senhora declarou chan é e neste
treinamento também foi longo
é eu tenho uma memória e não jamais vou
esquecer e ainda bem porque acho que é
importante não esquecer os momentos maus
e dá valor às linhas bons e nesta altura
lembro tenho um momento muito presente
foi os médicos já os pratos também não
estávamos a conseguir controlar a
situação entrarem no quarto dizendo e
marta está muito simples nós vamos
passar a fazer um tratamento menos
conservador do que temos feito até agora
por não ter resolvido entre nós vamos
fazer é é achamos que uma bactéria
bactérias está alojada na cabeça do
troféu mas nós temos que abrir para ver
estiver na cabeça do fêmur vamos limpar
a cabeça do fémur tanta gente não tem
cabeça do fêmur e posteriormente colocou
uma prótese
vamos limpar a cabeça do fêmur estiver
no fêmur
vamos ter que tirar a perna
se tiver passado por um lado direito o
lado esquerdo que estava no lado direito
lembro que era chefe do rabo
vamos ter que continuar a dar
antibiótico espra que tu reaja coisa que
nós sabemos já expliquei que não tinha
acontecido até agora porque o fato eu
voltava sempre é fazer febre
bom eu tenho 29 anos nessa altura eu
depois médicos íris foi calma manter a
calma vamos pro bloco e vamos ver o que
acontece
mais uma vez a marca dizer calma está se
resolvendo
e fui lembro de o caminho que eu fiz pro
bloco nós fazemos nas camas mãe nos
hospitais exames nesta manhã
andamos maca e quando passa o procurador
vai das minhas enfermarias e malta que
tratava de genário desde que tenha
entrado no primeiro treinamento a
dizerem carlos marta vai correr tudo bem
tem calma vai chegar aqui e vai estar
sábado
eu costumo dizer que os médicos salvaram
o corpo
- mas foi nos contrataram mas os
reformados em família e os amigos
informados salvar uma aula por fatos
foram muito importantes nessa altura
resta dizer que a cirurgia correu bem e
eu de fato tinha bateria usada na cabeça
do fémur deus nem param o período a
seguir recuperação foi brutal
ainda esta cirurgia foi muito complicada
e eu tive durante muito tempo a receber
antibiótico na própria ferida não fechar
um nó e é seguir essa é essa
essa recuperação muito demorada e
dolorosa
apesar de não ter dores havia outro tipo
do jornal é pior do que a dor física
elas se dão em que está na altura de ir
para casa fazer minha recuperação é em
sim eu vou novamente para o meu chefe
vou novamente para a minha casa para o
meio ambiente e foi aí que mim é a minha
minha parte psicológica se equilibrou
mas estava muito esperada já no hospital
eu estava a par de tudo é que eu estava
cá fora que eram os meus amigos é
carlota que misture edital bem como
alunos gravaram muita falta
foi um período muito doloroso mas também
foi um período muito importante e ao
colo e eu estou grata por ter passado
porque houve uma coisa que eu aprendi na
altura já uma coisa fantástica que
entraram na minha vida pessoas que nunca
mais serão
isso é ótimo nos piores momentos nós
vemos quem está lá
de fato eu ainda hoje mudou com muita
gente disse naquela altura e eu gosto
muito é mas acima de tudo aprendi não na
altura de cada época era uma miúda com
15 anos criança recebendo a capacidade
de ver as coisas pelo lado positivo
eu queria viver a vida e curtir ao
máximo e não preocupar com o resto
mas com 29 diferentes e aquilo que eu
queria nessa altura era aquilo que eu
consegui nessa altura foi de facto é
percebido nada garantido
nada é garantido nós às vezes não damos
valor às pequenas coisas têm que
acontecer mas nós precisamos coletar
lembro de ciclismo e cheias de vida nada
é garantido isso foi uma lição que
aprendi para a vida
e para a vida porque eu a uma marca
antes da cfm a tal como marcantes da
cadeira de rodas e outra depois fazer
cima tudo mata antes da cehap emília e
uma marta é seguir a cfm e quando eu
achava teradata última que as coisas
estavam mais ou menos equilibradas e
calmas na minha vida é isso que surge é
que está a data mais importantes até os
eu estou pensando em ficar pelo menos
até aos 90 anos talvez até os 40
terceira data que marca é minha
existência
estamos já em 2015 vai passar uns 16
meses antes mas atenção que agora na
doença está bem
esta é uma data positiva fechar esta
grande festa à altura desta desta data é
eu sei que eu tenho um blog onde contava
as minhas histórias em quadrinhos minhas
experiências e percebi que elas tenham
de fato muito impacto em explorar o fato
muito impacto nas pessoas à minha volta
e inspiravam da luminária estavam as
duas etnias feedback nesse sentido
daí e até é uma coisa popular não ter
convidado a escrever um livro sobre a
minha história foi um passo muito
curtinho e de repente em 2016 em março
de 2016
é parece na minha vida o livro é que eu
trago aqui com uma uma data que marca
por dois motivos a mãe é meu lugar como
virgínia que sou uma rapariga muito
organizada muito tóxica e o dae
desarrumação portanto tenha tido a
oportunidade de estruturar a minha vida
os meus 40 anos é histórias muito
específicas sabe aquelas já ajudavam as
outras pessoas foi fantástico mas acima
de tudo é ajudou a perceber que é e isso
deixa as coisas só conseguem de facto a
distância mas aconteceu que eu consegui
perceber que o meu corpo as situações
limita tem um padrão segundo padrão e o
padrão é um bem como chamar fama dos
mais fortes quando ficam com pouca
bateria o que acontece basicamente els
começam a deixar de fazer algumas
tarefas e algumas
é a funcionalidade fica um papel que
aconteceu com o meu corpo e eu na altura
tive que me focar esqueceram cada edição
esqueceram caso o valor da vida como eu
costumo dizer e munir trazer a minha
vida uma uma ferramenta que eu não
costumo usar você chin que o excel
eu só precisei de ficar toda a energia
que eu tinha na minha recuperação
nem a solução para o meu problema e
atenção que temos 42 problemas que vocês
conhecem mas há várias pessoas têm
vários problemas é que o primeiro já um
problema pra vocês podem não ser mas pra
mim é um problema o contrário também por
vocês é uma loucura pra mim é uma coisa
que eu tô com estalar de dedos
quando não conseguimos alguma coisa
importante que eu queria deixar também é
e ajuda me ajuda é de facto importante
não é ter vergonha quando não conseguiu
sozinhos têm que pedir ajuda seja colega
seja um amigo familiar seja um médico
que for ver os piraju até a mensagem que
eu estava estava deixar aqui era quando
nós temos de fato o problema porque
existem ao longo da nossa vida não há
nada a fazer
temos que parar temos que olhar de
frente de deus e enfrentá-lo esqueceram
que a minha parte emocional
às vezes não é fácil que os fez um
esforço nesse sentido e ficar toda é não
a cirurgia pouquinho como smartphone
precisa ser ligado a ficha tudo bem mas
enquanto não é ligado
vamos focar toda a nossa energia numa
função definir um plano uma estratégia e
seguir sempre em frente como burrinha
ensino na frente não tem mais nada a
cenoura ea solução é o terceiro problema
e esse é o segredo é ficar focado focar
e eu escolhi ser feliz você espero que
escolham todos os dias também seria
difícil
obrigado